you know Obama is still perhaps our best
hope but he's going to have to study
this problem and understand it presently
his approach is to let Congress debate
it and make their their horse trading
and end up with some sort of compromises
with the polluters and then we end up
with this cap and trade and offsets and
a completely ineffective system but this
isn't now this situation in which we can
see what we are doing to future climate
and what the implications will be for
young people we're we're in danger of
said sending them into a situation where
dynamical system will be out of their
control but this the intergenerational
injustice of that is this problem is
analogous to that faced by Abraham
Lincoln with slavery or Winston
Churchill with Nazism it's not a problem
where you can compromise Lincoln
couldn't say well let's reduce the
slaves by 50% yeah you can't compromise
on this we have to phase out the carbon
dioxide emissions over the next several
decades and and frankly that means
phasing out coal emissions and this cap
and trade system doesn't do it at all
are there taking the easy way out the
they're allowing the polluters to write
the bill the waxman-markey bill in the
house is 2,000 pages long do you think
that representative Waxman wrote this no
this is written by the polluters and
even by environmentalist their good
points in those bills also it's filled
with the polluters point of view and and
some environmental things to increase
solar power for example but that's not
going to solve the problem it's just
like the old Kyoto Protocol approach we
they have to face the fundamental issue
as long as fossil fuels are the cheapest
energy then they are going to be burned
and their use will continue to increase
you have to face that that's what the
lawmakers are not facing and that's what
President Obama has got to understand so
the only way you can address that is by
putting a rising price on the carbon
emissions then the alternatives the
renewable energies energy efficiency
nuclear power anything that doesn't
produce carbon will compete more
effectively and those which are most
effective will begin to win economically
yes there are people in Washington to
get it there there is one bill that was
introduced in the house which had a
gradually increasing carbon price the
democratic party was introduced by a
Democrat I'm sorry I can't think of his
name at the moment but it was
conveniently ignored by the Democratic
Party we've got to have a an open
discussion of this I think you know the
public is not excited about this issue
the way they were about health care but
we need to have that kind of in an open
discussion so that we see what the
alternatives are because this approach
that is being pushed by the Democratic
Party is a disaster